so David that we turned to first
Corinthians 15 where Paul is dealing
with issues connected with the
resurrection what's the issue that's on
the table here I'm glad we're having
this conversation because I have been
wrestling with this for as long as I've
been wrestling with New Testament text
which is a lot of years now I'm clearer
on what he thinks the solution is and
what he thinks the issue is and the
solution is to insist on the reality of
Jesus resurrection as being central to
Christian faith and to insist that
following Jesus believers will also be
raised what's he worried about what we
know when he's worried about speaking in
tongues we know he's worried about
inappropriate abstinence in marriage
what's the worry here my impression is
and I'm I really want your response to
this my impression is that this is a
group of people who believes in Jesus
resurrection he can say that that's
something they all have in common but
for whatever reasons are not convinced
that they too will be raised at the last
day and whether this is because they
think they'll just die and go away or
whether it's because they think their
souls will be raised I can't tell but it
seems to me that the point of the
argument is not so much to convince them
that Jesus is raised as to convince them
that because they believe Jesus is
raised they then need to believe in the
general resurrection or they can't make
any sense of the claim that Jesus is
raised is that see I think that's right
the way I've tried to imagine what's
going on in the minds of the the
Corinthians is in part to look forward
okay the second century and in part to
look back to the first century BC and we
know in the second century that there
were some people that we even have hints
of it later out of the New Testament
people who were denying the physical
character of the resurrection and so
they're probably coming out of some sort
of greco-roman philosophical miliar that
emphasizes the immortality of the soul
so it may be that these Corinthians
believe in the resurrection of Christ
but interpret it in that way yeah it
another indication of what this this
conceptually might be can be found i
think in the wisdom of Solomon a text
written in Jewish circles probably in
Alexandria probably first century BC
that talks about
they the souls of the US yep being in in
the hand of God and therefore they don't
have to tell me so that there you see
the language of greco-roman culture
being taken over in a Jewish environment
affirming some sort of immortality but
not being so much worried about the
resurrection of the body now some people
think that the resurrection of the body
is a widespread Jewish belief yes it's
there and Judaism but it's not
universally no means universal right and
i think the wisdom of Solomon is an
example of another mentality and that
would tie in with them all the stuff we
saw at the beginning about wisdom and
they suggested maybe Apollo saw
something to do with Alexandra with
Alexandria yeah so it might be coming to
be that source yeah so I think that's
what Paul was trying to counter there
are people in this congregation who
believe in the resurrection of Jesus all
right but understand the implications
for them in terms of the immortality of
their soul and this is another part of
that general phenomenon we've seen with
this kind of curious attitude toward the
body I disembodied Christian I isn't one
of his big concerns from beginning to
end and so here we have now what what is
our hope our hope is not that we escaped
from our bodies but that our bodies be
raised as Jesus has been raised then we
get this complicated business about what
what is it to be raised and his almost
oxymoronic claim that will be raised not
as physical bodies but as spiritual
bodies I puzzle about that a lot and I
think I'm clearer on its pastoral
implications than on its philosophical
routines and the pastoral implications
have something to do with the claim that
oh when the dead are raised it's still
we who are raised that is it's not some
spiritual emanation from ourselves or
some reductant essence of ourselves but
that it is the real hairy Attridge who
will be raised the real David Bartlett
who will be raised but he also knows
it's not presumably we won't be raised
to conversations like this sitting here
in our typical though I don't we will
but as fun as it would be
um chatting away for eternity but that
that somehow just as Christ has been
glorified so we will participate in some
richer glory in that day coming yeah
this is another case where Paul seems to
be addressing both sides of a debate and
trying to affirm something on both sides
ring them together so in later on in the
chapter and verse 50 he'll say flesh and
blood will not inherit the care of God
so this seems to reaffirm the position
that he's already criticized the
position of the Corinthians would
denying the objective reality of future
resurrection right so how does he do
that at the same time emphasize the body
through through some sort of reflection
on what kinds of bodies there might be
and that is what we get in verse 35 yeah
following yeah and they're even though
it's a little obscure I think what he's
he's he does two things first of all
just that the metaphor of a seed be and
the plant that grows up from the
Seahawks very different on the sea one
of the early rigid religion in nature
conversations religion in science and
then yeah he turns to science yeah
philosophy and says that there were
different kinds of bodies our earthly
bodies and heavenly bodies and I think
what he's calling on there is no shins
that we can find in Aristotelian
cosmology for instance and widespread in
the Hellenistic world that they were
different different elements that
include the four that everybody
recognizes earth air fire and water but
there's another kind of element that is
the substance of the stars the ether who
what later in the Renaissance would be
called the quintessence you know the
fifth essence the fifth substance and so
if stars are made out of this ethereal
stuff that looks an awful lot like
spirit like coma that pervades all
things that Paul says is kind of one
more like more like like what our bodies
are going to be a different kind of body
than whatever we experience in this
sublunar coughs fear but it is
nonetheless an objective body and and I
think with that in mind we reflect back
on the rest of the letter and see how
often he's wanted to say God has made us
as
bodies as embodied person so sex counts
and how you treat your brothers and
sisters in the body of Christ counts
because this is all not only part of
God's creation but part of God's
redemptive plan what God intends to
redeem is not that little spiritual part
of you that can simply be immune from
bodily concerns but the real you which
is body now one of the things Paul does
right at the beginning of this argument
is to give us a little bit of tradition
yeah the resurrection of Christ and but
what do you make of that well it's it's
striking in that he draws on something
as in the as in first Corinthians 11
where he talked about a story about the
Last Supper that he got here he talks
about a story about resurrection that he
got and its its appearance language he
may know the story of the empty tomb but
it's not in here what we do have in here
is that after his resurrection Christ
appeared then a list of the witnesses
and then I think not coincidentally
taking us back to an earlier theme one
of the witnesses is Paul himself because
he's still trying to remind everybody
that he's an apostle that he stands in
that line but it's a way of saying that
the fundamental faith in which they live
absolutely depends on the claim that
Christ is risen and if they don't
believe that then they're not really in
the Christian community at all there are
there are some places where some things
you can't let go and still be part of
this body part of this family but it's a
perhaps a different idea of what
resurrection is from what we might infer
from let's say the gospel I think it may
very well be on because we just we don't
have empty tomb we don't have a sense of
what those appearances are we don't have
Jesus walking through doors we just it's
very reticent about all that and I think
I just don't know what if you'd said
Paul what did he look like I don't know
they did have an answer for us and two
at the end of his argument he he uses
language of the mysterious from yep yep
and what do you make of all of that well
mystery is a big word for Paul and it
has to do with secrets hidden from the
foundation of the earth but also it's
very often used for for eschatological
language for the claim about what God is
going to do at the end of all time and
we said all along that one thing Paul
won't let go and it's part of his great
strength
part of his great problem for us is this
claim that the consummation of all
things is coming and coming soon and
this drives us straight toward that and
says that the mystery is that at the end
everything will be changed and and the
other thing that's always struck me in
this in this chapter and you may know
remember the exact person I'd known at
the moment is is that claim let me back
off and do it slightly differently Paul
loves the future of Christ and Paul
loves the future human embodied beings
but at the end of everything he wants to
say his claim is deeply Theo centric
that at the end of the story God will be
all in all there will be all things to
all people and I think I think we are we
are appropriately so interested in what
what Paul thinks about Jesus and what
Paul thinks about us that we sometimes
forget that fundamental claim in which
he stands with his Jewish tradition
which says God in the beginning and God
in the end and everything else in the
middle including our Lord and Savior is
in the service of that mmm there's a
marvelous passage at the end he waxes
poetic doesn't he studying Scripture
death has been swallowed up in victory
where O death is your victory where O
death is your sting and then a curious
and various little moment to two rivers
to one of his written letters Simmons in
the law but thanks be to God who gives
us the victory through our Lord you
surprised it's a great it's an
astonishing promise and I think Paul
wants to say that without that hope
without that not just for ourselves but
for the whole creation Christianity
falls far short of the faith and hope
and love to which he calls it and on
that point we can call into our
compensation you up to